gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you standup comedy plus we
play a little AIG with the crowd shows
are selling out and you can get your
tickets at rug garbage.com see it
[Music]
there welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is Ru garbage it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it that
they group up to be classy but they're
just a big old piece of trash garbage
I'm your host H Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here with
toties in the new edition she's upstairs
with the girls from the book club okay
bunch of nerds the hell out of my way
sitting in a circle in the living room
hey beat it four eyes don't watch a
movie I got a pod to do down St m co is
coming at from across the table it's a
family episode just the boys the bozos
and the homies just the way we like it
he is the CEO of Ru garbage
International businessman sure King of
the boardwalk King of the boards the
flatbread bre also new one king of the
BBS oo it's not bad right sulan of the
suburbs all right where you're at or the
Kevin James Ryan everybody big man not
quick on his feet what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in as always pleas
make sure you r subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are
TR then obviously the greatest one of
the greatest goorm websites of all time
www.patreon.com
garbage you go over there you get all
your bonus content all things a they got
bonus vids tons of bonus vids tour life
stuff Road Vlogs all over car pots
everything you needs over there gang
hard feelings check it the freak out hit
of the Season that hard feelings it is
and then we also have rug garbage.com
you go over there and you get all the
tickets to the state trashy tour which
are limited in some
cities some cities are doing great some
not so good all but one all but one get
those tickets we want to we want to see
you out there it's a great freaking time
and also he cops a merch gang shout out
to the Roto gang there you go look at
you my [__] laundry day needs to come
soon Kippy poel over there said it
didn't forget it and have a nice quick
shout out to our producer sh there the
old magic man over there very funny
standup comedian from the backwoods of
North Carolina
by way of Chicago Illinois give it up
for the old magic man T-Bone MC scruffs
Toby mcwell everybody our good pal what
up boys up kid I can't wait for hoodie
weather dude it's right around the
corner in baby I think it's here uh well
it's peeking it's creeping it's day it's
day to day sure day to day it sneaks up
on oh nothing worse than than you get
like four days of like cold crisp fall
and then you walk outside it's 80° again
yeah AIT got a jacket on Swit butting
your dick off chilly on the slow
cooker [__] jamming me up already
soed the driveway let's
go um were you uh were you a shorts or
pants guy first day of school back to
school shorts yeah shorts first day of
school never really shorts really you
think my legs are bad now really as a
kid so you never wore shorts to school
never I thought you would be one of
those shorts all winner kind of guys I
wasn't fat in high school I was [__]
trim 71 huh you never you've never worn
a pair of shorts to school maybe when I
was at like like what once that pair of
boy shorts I remember hi
puppy said you look you got to grab
now uh no once uh female once girls came
into the picture you know hi in those
knobby knees so hiding everything okay
yeah what was that 2013
igy yeah seventh eighth ninth no never
never seven this was more I'm talking
fourth fifth sixth was always like are
you going to wear jeans or are you going
to do shorts still now Patty was running
the show then I wasn't allowed to pick
what I wore she still does we're being
honest she stinks lays out your clothes
for you I wish you would um no we that
was that was the big thing that's how I
didn't get into acting as a child
because I I had an audition for a Sears
commercial and she wanted me to wear
like a par you got to wear a nice
parinos and a button-up shirt and I
wanted to wear this like
velour uh burgundy Adidas sweatsuit I
thought I thought I'd
wow I thought I'd wow them and she I I
wouldn't change and she's like then I'm
not taking you could had a career in my
hands there a child actor that's
something that you wear when you're
producing adult videos yeah what do you
think I was going hey guys I'm also In
The Biz I do on screen and all behind
the camera work if you need anything
yeah but no yeah Patty called the shots
then okay um well I mean I would when I
up until fourth grade I was in Catholic
school and it was all you know you had
to dress up I want to grab it you try
try to hide as much as blend in with the
crow wearing a ghillie suit you kidding
me chewing on garlic trying to keep me
away from my sweet bottom um but yeah no
never never never never shorts you a
shorts guy actually you know what I take
that back what am I talking about I
don't know lacrosse shorts with the
boxers hanging out below them probably
in ninth
grade the sure the that was in for I
don't remember that mean huge that was
huge maybe May the boxers had to hang
out below the lacrosse shorts they had
to come down further than the lacrosse
shorts that's the way everybody rocked
them that's a horrible look that's why
my nuts are down at my ankles too like
like
boxer shorts in the GU SK did either of
you ever Rock the double t-shirt yeah oh
yeah I would still do it now if it was
socially acceptable for sure I drap
myself in double t-shirts for sure yeah
you're nuts the long sleeve tea no no no
double short sleeve oh yeah yeah but I'm
saying long sleeve tea with the short
sleeve tea over top for sure the thermal
that was big the therm the thermal was
big the white thermal um was there
nothing better than that I had one that
I stole from Phil X shout out to Phil x
man this thing I don't know his parents
must have been making them or something
this thing was sweet had had Irish cor
bomb stains all over it though that's
awesome it was great though uh but
double t-shirt for a long time yeah but
only especially for a fat kid oh yeah
you get that extra layer of titty meat
it's like wearing a Superman suit yeah
uh it depended upon the collars the
collars really had to match up if you
had a bunk collar under it was bad if
you had one on top his bad so not all
shirts matched up they had to match up
in the way we at the at the time in the
in the in the early 90s was a tighter
one underneath and a looser one around
it and you looked real cool real grunge
yeah it was all about the grunge back
then um there was some that I remember I
would always try to do it uh I would
have like two of the same for some
reason two of the same t-shirt never
worked cuz they were identical so it it
always just like lump like it never in
my head it should fit perfectly I
remember but it was a fraction of a
fraction of a millimeter off and you're
all dude you're like pulling it up it's
stuff it's scrunched up I remember when
I realized that undershirts were
different than t-shirts I don't know
what you mean when I put that like a
Hanes t-shirt sure yeah they like I
couldn't never understand why why am I
why do I look like an idiot why are my
tits hanging out and it was because it's
that thin undershirt material sure it's
not yet yeah yeah no that that stuff for
sure uh there's some pictures of me as a
relative adult of drinking and voting
age triple
t-shirts with my I think I was wearing
like a I'd wear like Polo or like shirts
like an under like a double tea Andor
like a t-shirt and like a golf shirt
like a polo shirt or whatever and the
undershirt was too long and it was
hanging out dude like a a 2in white
thing you cuz you you put it on you like
tuck it up you're like oh I'll be good
then you get out in the world you start
moving around start operating it's bad
news dude it's a lot different in the
simulator I looks like I got dressed in
the lost and F get out there on the
streets it was bad yeah looks like you
borrowed someone's clothes but in high
school I tried to go cool
jeans nice boots and like a double te or
something like that do that you know try
to look I don't care yeah it's HCK that
we were jeans there was definitely some
gunit T-shirts that I got at TJ ma man I
remember finding a cash of gunit
t-shirts at a TJ Maxx on Street Road
dude you couldn't tell me nothing it was
like
dude catch a lineup in the XL section I
was like finding the [__] Holy Grail
dude that thing was glowing I used to
hate going around that thing cuz it
would be like small large and like
you're on like the left corner going
around the rack I got to be honest with
you it took me too fat too fat too fat
too fat it took me a long time to
realize they were different quality
stores
what do you mean I didn't know TJ Maxx
we were a TJ Maxx
family I didn't realized that
was shittier quality Endor defected or
what are you an idiot it was never why
we were going there no we're going to TJ
Maxx it was never positioned like that
in my head it was just run to TJ Maxx
and grab a you know what it was more of
like a I'd run and get a pair of khakis
cuz I was had a christening and I was
too too fat for the other ones you know
or something and but I took me get dress
clothes there man oh every every dude I
I remember was my sisters oh this is so
bad that place should have been called
blisters you picked up a pair of dresses
oh my God we got the sharpest shoes in
the biz dude like a Vietnamese booby
trap just slicing your Achilles over
it's like all the all the nails are
facing in so you go and you can't get
out holy [__] uh
my
sister's uh uh rehearsal dinner
rehearsal like I was in the wedding so
it was like a rehearsal know it was like
khakis in a shirt a good rehearsal
dinner they were fun just a family low
low stakes just fun real quick run
through minutes dinner okay um and I
didn't had no I had nothing to wear
right this is prime fluctuating between
like fat and fatter and no idea of how
to dress like no I like I didn't have a
I was just wearing clothes that ended up
in the house you know what I mean yeah
like do I don't know whose pants these
are but they've been fitting you know
that type they might have been my
brothers or my brother's friends or my
dad like they're just there's a pair of
khakis that been in the bottom this
bottom drawer for four years let me see
if they fit and I went to get khakis
dude and I just like I didn't try
nothing on and I grabbed this pair of
khakis and ran home and now everybody's
there all she's early 20 so like all her
friends cousins it's like you know 40
people or whatever is that when she got
married early 20s I think so nice yeah
uh mid yeah something like that um and I
go now everyone's up there everyone's at
my mom's house I run in with a bag from
TJ Maxx they're all there just that's
that is my life I'm such a [__] smell
like heers Micky D's I know your fat ass
stopped up and grabbed the McDouble real
quick nope it was Arby's it was in the
same parking
lot shout out to the street road dude
that's when you know you're real trash
you're buying a pair of pants you don't
think can fit but you still got room in
the budget and in your brain for a
[__] Hardies yeah yeah the curly
fries keep you coming back uh Arby sucks
dude you that was the height of my life
in that moment bu I was I was guessing
on pants for a party that had started
you trying them on no that's the story
that I get home you just asked the guy
at the drivethru think he fit all give
me
two they look like a little snug all
right throw me a banana shake wash this
down um parties happening I run
in go upstairs the party at your house
the pre party I think we're all meeting
there we're all driving over the party's
in his pants if they can fit they were
so your family are booze bags who
pregame for a rehearsal dinner Jesus
Christ I don't mean pregame I mean they
are booze bags I'm not taking that away
from them they've earned it myself
included no I don't think anybody was
drinking put the ice lose
away got to meet the priest in 20
minutes I wasn't uh no I think there was
people from out of town who were like
let's just meet here then we'll all go
to the church or whatever it was um we
weren't drinking we were having beers
there is that is different I had a beer
versus I was
drinking I may have a
problem a few beers what have it no uh
um man and I now dude talk about being
Behind Enemy Lines I'm in my childhood
bedroom putting I put my shirt on the
shirt fits I go to put those pants on
you know when you pull them out of the B
like you're like I'm like this ain't
this ain't going to work dude they must
have been like 40 those TJ Maxx bags
were unforgiving too I don't know what
they were made of but they were
something weird yeah just had a bad Omen
to uhhuh uh the handle get all stretched
out and stuff like what the even the bag
stun yeah might as well wear
this hey maybe you can fit your fat head
through this
handle man and I had to walk down these
I was swimming in these things oh they
were too big oh man and
everybody I look like [__] Tracy
McGrady dude it was
bad it looked so and I remember being
like what you do last
night I remember sitting there going I I
got to get my [__] act like and I've
never that's why like I'm a big I'm
always so concerned with how I dress now
for events sure because I never landed
it ever ever ever never I still never
have I've never watch no when we did uh
Casey and Robbie's W you looked
fantastic you went out and got that new
suit that blue suit that looks F dude
you put that on now go get that [__]
hemmed up you think like a million bucks
was I fatter then oh
yeah I us to say it like that oh
baby I mean if you weren't 12 yeah um
the answer is going to be yeah no you
look [__] great in that yeah go get
that taken in h start wearing that
around look like a million bucks dud you
look great mock turtleneck undern that
thing little gold look like the Rocks
manager cutting deals uh one thing I'll
give Patty and I know you know she
babied me but into my
30s I was a bozo if there was something
like that it was in her best interest to
make sure that I was covered on that
stuff even into your 30s so if I if it
was something family if it was something
family
related okay I got a couple Uncle Mike
suits I made sure they were dry cleaned
right that's a little different I got
you a belt there I there shoes here of
your father's that you can wear she made
sure because she because I'm an
extension you know I'm working for the
company at that point is that how you
view it that's how she view no that's
how she viewed it you don't mind that
Viewpoint no I enjoyed it sure yeah I
think that's why you're
so uh and a couple of ones for the
bar why she's giving you [__] pocket
money man talk about it and Patty cut
the cord what are you doing hey she's
been well rewarded I'll say that she's
taken care of now she don't pay for gems
one uncle Hank
yeah finally a 47 you started [__]
paying her back longterm
investment paying off but I think she
got ice stripping on her she does okay
that broad like 900 grand for three
lunches 40 years later yeah I know what
900 there's TJ Maxx and Marshalls
secondhand suits still popsicles alone
probably [__] sucked or dry um she
gets those outshine man I didn't know
that was the case that makes so much
sense I think well she the thing with us
was she it was yeah try to talk yourself
out of this one
easily behind no it's not going to work
behind closed doors it was behind closed
doors was one thing but we kept it in
the family so she wanted to make sure
everybody looked presentable when they
were out you're pushing 40 you should be
able I said close to 30 you said into
your 30s is the the nomenclature you
used okay okay [__] stenographer over
here this guy everything I [__] say
no no no no no this this goes in deeper
you say stuff I respond it's a eism no
that's not even a thing
hyperbole you just you just said
stenographer which is a guy who makes
maps and then you said you you idiot no
you're wrong man we are three idiots oh
it's a cartographer [__] somebody get me
my big
pants I'll be I'll be the I'll be the
I'll be the guy here cartographer
cartographer stenographer is the guy in
court
top topography topog topography yes I
think it's the heights though I thought
it was a store in the mall that's
anthropology oh which I don't know what
they sell the bird goes in there and I
go any place that smells like incense or
candle too much I'm out catch me at the
[__] Fridays in a corner can't and
like I want to have okay I don't want to
have an opinion but when you get called
into the store what do you think it's
it's nice I don't know get it I know
it's it's a hacky thing I get it but I
have it too it's you're just like I
don't know what do you want me to say
I'll [__] you I [__] you yeah yeah get I
got I got no yeah feel like sometimes
they want to get your opinion just to
have just to shoot it down no but it's
this you know sh no sure you get what
I'm saying no I mean I think that's what
you think goes on in your head sure oh
I'm crazy yeah I'd lean that I'd lean
that I don't think anybody's ever asked
my opinion just to say no I feel like
that's what everybody does this exp this
this explains our work life so well they
say what do you think of this so they
can prove their point does that make
sense no no but this now makes a lot of
other stuff make a lot of sense really
you're talking to the guy who you've
done that the most to probably in the
past three years like if you said hey
I'm going to wear my hair this way what
do you think no I think you should
shorten it up no but I like it like this
I think a lot of people do do that oh
okay they want to strengthen their
opinion they want to flex their opinion
on you and no matter what you say I
guess we interpreted that differently
yes okay I see what you're saying who's
crazy now yeah we were thinking more
about like uh like like video stuff
where I'm like because I value your
opinion highly on on that stuff sure as
you should well now I
don't he's such a [__] sucker oh my God
it's all head
games just when you think you're out it
takes you right right back to
fville any you should because I'm
smarter and better looking than you next
K let's talk about sheath shout out to
shiz baby podcast OG that sheath
underwear absolutely fantastic best
underwear you could buy I love them
developed by a military veteran mhm for
hot days over there in Iraq Robert
Patton yeah keeping your nut separator
from your wiener so everybody stays cool
crisp and you keep the head on straight
especially when we got the when you got
the nickel out you know what I
mean can't be Fu can't have your ball
bag all twisted up gang here's how it
works you got there's one pouch for your
dick one pouch for your ball so
everything isn't mashed together like
yesterday's tuna fish you know what I'm
saying cre up by us Sergeant Robert
Patton sheath was made to be to
withstand the heat of the Iraqi desert
so you know it'll keep you cool yeah
when you're sitting in your Corola not
fighting for this gosh darn country you
know what I mean same thing uh they were
they're I mean I've said this bajillion
time shout out to sheath they were one
of I think the first when we went on on
the first Advertiser they came and uh
supported the show so support them I
love the underwear it's fantastic I got
everybody in my family wearing I'm a big
salesman of the undies they sell
themselves uh my dick looks great and
feels amazing so I'm told and yours will
too stock up on sheath underwear and
give your crown jewels some airf flow so
go to sheath underwear. comom use the
code garbage to get 20% off your first
order plus sheath underwear 100 % money
back guarantee that sheath underwear.
comom promo code garbage get sheath
underwear support the show support your
balls do it K like about fitbod shout
out to fitbod gang sticking to the same
old old workout routine is going to lead
to a plateau Shake It Up with fitbod the
fitbod app is like having a personal
trainer in your pocket it creates custom
workouts based on your goals your
experience and your available equipment
no matter where you are or what
equipment you have fitbod will create a
custom workout that'll get your best
body possible yeah uh we're in the
middle of fat court right now we're
trying to stay
active I went over to my phone and
downloaded fitbod activ and it gives you
everything you need to know easy peasy
it tells you how to do it well balanced
workout plan just for you tracks muscle
fatigue recovery with over 1,000 demo
videos so you ain't got to guess what
you're doing you can see it being done
learn how to do the movements the right
way you can even track your personal
best with fit bods progress charts baby
it's never been easier to get the
results you've always wanted check out
fitbod get 20 5% off your subscription
at fitbod domme garbage that's fitbod
fitbod d.m garbage do it gang fitbot
fitbot I am fitbot out I wanted to ask
is this not that big of a deal but I
kind of noticed it today and obviously I
respect the Working Man you know what I
mean a lot of construction going on out
on the streets you know what I mean you
know this time of year a lot of
construction and I respect that what I
kind of an over
am over is I don't mind the
construction I do mind when the
construction guys try to play traffic
cop I disagree with this listen that
ain't the head guy that's not the sharp
guy on the squad is the guy spinning the
slow stop stick oh you don't like that
guy I don't I just they should just have
a traffic cop there to move that along
they shouldn't have to do
it and they're not really the best at
doing
it half of the time it's halfway stop or
slow you don't know what the hell you're
doing okay I don't love it that that I
just have a little bit of a beef with
that okay and there's a lot of
attitude sometimes with those they
charge that they are the king of traffic
at that point but they're not then they
shouldn't have to be but they are yeah
they are they're tell they're telling
you're fat ass to stop I know yeah it's
it is frustrating especially in the city
yes obviously that is very uh it is very
frustrating driv me nuts um today
especially it's like [__] what are
you doing they should have to do a class
or something how to do that that's
always the boo on the crew put Murray on
that or something like that it's never
the [__] brain they the best guy
should be doing that no what what kind
of operation are you running you're
never going to win a bid got your best
guy flipping the sign you'd be out of
business the unions be all over you gas
lines left and right that traffic was
moving
though got Gary on the boom cran [__]
taken out the Empire State
Building uh sure okay um I yeah it's it
you have a construction background yeah
it can get uh they to stick you out
there on that one uh no no I thought you
meant the guy uh who will if they're
like the it's not that guy who's in the
charge of the flow of traffic it's the
guy who they're moving something so he
jumps out and goes oh that guy you
respect love that guy yeah that guy's
good guy they're backing at the Bobcat
I'm not a [__] [__] Hey cuz that
to me and I get because hold on that guy
will punch you in the face too right
there's an authoritative thing with the
guy with the sign you got to for
whatever reason it's the flow tra you
got to boo on the crew that's my problem
yeah he's on his boots on the ground I
mean you can't have the you can't have
the best guy out there maybe not the
best guy give me the second best guy or
make the engineer the boo on the crew is
making the coffee run that's what he's
doing that guy ain't the bottom of the
the boo is he's in the deli ordering 48
coffees jamming me up when I'm trying to
get a
panini oh man I used to you go in at the
[__] Deli I when I worked at the law
firm and get breakfast man you get
behind a guy who has a big like a ripped
off piece of
cardboard I need 32 omelet you're like
[__] me just trying to get it's either
coffees or lottery tickets [__] need my
bacon egg and cheese yeah um when I
worked at the law firm sounds so much
more prestigious than the actual work
involved before I was asked to
leave my secretary
[Laughter]
job yeah I used to have a pretty good
professional resume it looked really
good on paper it did I could get in
there was a couple of law you always had
office jobs you weren't [__] you know
waiting tables like me you you you were
shirt and tie to work no no tie dirty
never a tie a lot of dirty clothes worn
to work and I was always real fast and
loose with the um what's the not the
Wardrobe what's the word
the office polish code dress code there
you go yeah I would break I would never
you you took business casual
to its limits yeah it was 5:00 somewhere
baby take me away to Margarita hi look
gu was tailgate and a Jimmy Buffett
concert man uh the Herold of happy hour
well my thing was if you
never for the everybody out there this
this was always my my scam at a new job
everybody dresses to impress right away
right at the new job new job oh my God
don't do that really you're setting your
own bar too high you're not going to get
you're going to get the job though no
you on the I wore a suit to the to the
interview never see this again I still
can't believe I got that job dude that
was which one that one that on Park
Avenue the last one man I walked in
there that was the nicest building I've
ever been in dude I was like what the
[__] I was working for a pump and dum
scam before that it was and I was
sitting there I'm like there's no way
they're giving me this job and they're
like like we and I was like I dude he
probably get rid to pit everything on
you I know I thought I was going to be
the Fall Guy for a little for a few but
you're on a plate private playing in
South America uhhuh that was if comedy
didn't work if I wasn't doing comedy
that was a job you get and keep really
for 50 years no kidding yeah like you
that was would you have moved up in the
ranks uh I'm sure I remember dude I I
started working there and then four
weeks later they gave me a raise I was
like yo I no one in my family ever got a
raise in four weeks let's go I called my
mom dude it was a whole thing throw out
that big pants I didn't know
what I don't need it no more T say
goodbye to TJ Maxx um that uh having
friends that worked office and then
worked you know either Construction Blue
Collar way to table service inry kind of
stuff was different well you you were a
happy hour guy right no never uh-uh you
never a happy hour guy the only time I
ever went out drinking with people at
work I was always enthralled with the
happy hour scene no you had to do kai to
meet you to do [__] bar shows that's
right I would take a change of clothes
to change out of the business casule
clothes in work and then go meet you to
do shows I've never done happy hour once
in my life I've never been to a happy
hour I did I was I worked at a bunch of
them and people when I worked at the the
Waterfront Ale House uh on 30 30th and
2nd these [__] Dental students would
come in and the happy hour was only at
the bar and they would [__] order
[__] from the bar and then sit at the
tables like [__] [__] ah Jam y
up [__] told two or three of them
[__] cuz they tried me first I'm like
no they can't and it wasn't me it was
the [__] rules of the bar listen
hands are tied yeah so they would get
you from the bar and sit down [__]
pricks seem to be over it [__]
lunatic venison nachos I remember the
specific table oh the food at that place
venison nachos un believable it was
unbelievable I've never even thought of
that and chili every single thing was
homemade there was Unreal the guy hadit
a deer on the way to work what the
[__] buddy try a chicken or something
will
you dude they had chicken figures that
would [__] they had venison hes it
was always on the menu knock your socks
off unbelievable um but they go back to
the dress code never go high go in low
cuz they're not going to say something
to you the first couple of days you're
new I was no it's whatever no one's
going to chastise the new guy so always
set the bar low and then you're just
like oh yeah Kevin wears that to the
point where I was khakis which were not
supposed to be it had to be like slacks
or whatever you would call them suit
pants pants dress pants love a dress
pant I know but not when you're every
day cuz then I could wear the khakis on
stage can't go on [__] stage in the
dress pants so that was one less I did
got suit pants and a foo fighter shirt
on I would do that did that for about
three years I was suit pants yeah I wore
my Uncle Mike suit pants remember those
pinstripe ones no wor them all not known
you at that time no you did I wore them
sneakers and I had like t-shirts I knew
the only no the only you I knew was you
in dirty jeans that you wore waiting T
that looked like you had just weighted
tables oh yeah and that Zoo York
shirt Zoo York remember I was like color
like yellow it was black and it was like
blue and yellow and I feel like it was a
it was yours I thought my
no I think that's when I met you okay I
had a couple of your t-shirts sure yeah
when you lost the weight mhm it was all
right a couple of kippies man remember
we was talking about it I was telling
new guy Luke about it uh this is a nice
little walk down memory lane here uh
went to remember yellow rat bastard on
the lower east or in SoHo or something
we thought that place was Zack Smith
Avenue dude do you remember that dude it
was the era of the graphic T man this
place was the size of a Home
Depot and it was filled with graphic
te's everything made in banglades dude I
thought I was [__] Kim Kardashian
walking into that place you thought I
was like Cole's like 19 t-shirts for $3
uhhuh man get you through the week
[__] was all right thought I was
[__] doing it switching out of my
business casual clothes to a yellow rat
bastard t-shirt yeah it was good stuff
to go bomb for three people mhm
man yeah I got a good deal it's a
regular one long sleeve one short sleeve
it's just a cooler [__] TJ Maxx
that's all it is I mean a glance you
don't even see the misprint let's do
some Q's uh yes Family episode here
family go darn up gang uh as you know
when you sign up for patreon we will
answer your questions on the air we get
a lot of submissions but the homies know
they get the first freaking crack at oh
yeah um this one is more of this is just
a statement this is from Scott shout out
to you it's pretty classy to drink
mimosas even if you're not at brunch
right this is tough to
me cuz it is a brunch Breakfast
early morning there's got to be
breakfast food involved I
feel I don't know if I agree with that
there was a
repositioning of the Mimosa and the
balini bini's within a little different
I feel 10 years ago
I think and also to be honest with you
the you know the prco and the Cava the
sparkling wine that's all significantly
different than to me than the Mimosa
theoretically it is traditionally you
know you're talking 70s 80s 90s
beginning of the 2000s I'd say up until
about 2008 the Mimosa and the and the
Mimosa all right we'll leave bellinis
out of it which is just peach juice
um we're tra we're strictly
brunch
but when are people I don't know when
I've never seen them they've never been
all the only time I see them is at
airports an early dinner an early dinner
I think there's a 300 p.m. cut off yeah
on I'm telling you that's I mean I was I
was I was in the [__] then people were
ordering mimosas you would get some you
know all of a mimosa you know for an
early dinner I was frowned upon but they
would do it yeah I I got big into me for
a while that's a little different yeah
that's different yeah yeah but that's
also but it's very similar to the Bloody
Mary I feel like it's also a good brunch
drink yes sure yeah in that regard sure
I mean that would be weird if somebody
ordered a Bloody Marry and [__]
dinner [__] wrong with you Jesus Christ
that guy's got the DTs I'll have I'll
have a 9 oz filet Bloody Mar how a
divorce going buddy H uh I think you'd
be hard the only problem not against it
the only problem is like it's such a
curveball to order when everybody else
is drinking a beer it's like it's a wild
curveball it is it's it's a bit of a
curveball I'm not against it it's
something that you know like a nice lady
would
get really yeah no that's trashy that's
trashy after that if the sun goes down
that's trashy no a nice lady would just
get champagne she wouldn't juice it sure
orange that's breakfast I'm telling you
from experience who has ordered it from
me in the past sure
never never it's it's not an iron worker
I'm not saying it's wrong I'm just
saying it's not it's weird yeah it's a
little weird it's trash what I'm telling
you is that convention has loosened up a
little bit okay okay you know I believe
you but my Tommy Gun don't um all right
let's see
here you're not getting
bottomless that time of night there a
couple Moses I'll take my pants
off uh no they're really they [__] you
up in a a weird way dude there was this
place in you're going to throw up there
was this place in Harlem did bottomless
bottomless ipas when they first dropped
my god dude me and my boy would go and
black the [__] out in like minutes what
do you mean a brunch yeah they had a
bottomless you could do bottomless
mimosas bottomless you know something
else and then bottomless ipas and it was
like a German place it's called beer
stasa and they would give you like the
22 like the [__] heavy
how do you say get out in German oh man
dude that's insane we would [__] dude
we would go on a r we' run every ever I
take that in pancak oh man it was a
barbecue I was like we were doing like
schnitzel or like [__] sausages and
[__] Kil basa we were [__] up in there
it was like 40 bucks to add bottomless
ipas oh my God talk about [__]
calling the cops
woo uh all right let's see on the same
vein as and the same since we're doing
alcoholic beverages this what I'm
craving um is a garbage to chase shots
with milk what the [__] probably works
man think about it not if you're a
private
eye it it's got to be pretty good it's
got to kick the taste it's thick it's
like a coating you know what I mean you
need no I understand the
reasoning the guy who does that also
says [__] like I mean I know she's my
cousin but she's looking pretty good
like that's total creep I'm all right
with that
uh I don't know I mean I see it but
chasing shots with milk is milk good for
chasing alcohol milk the most mainstream
weird chase you can find most people
will have some kind of milk in the
fridge yeah it cleanses your pallet of
any alcohol let me say this most
bars unless it's brunch you ask a
bartender if you have any milk you're
going to get some push back uh I guess
he that's definitely a conversation
starts open up a bunch of tiny creamers
yeah that's definitely a conversation
he's going to have at the end of the bar
with a server go back and see if we have
any milk back there but I have to and
it's not going to be cold I have to push
back on this a little bit you're not
getting a chaser at a bar that's out a
house you can ask for a Coke back or a
pickleback a pickle back's different no
you're paying for it I've never seen
anybody ask for a chaser at a bar I have
all the time
yeah let me get a yeah what a chaser a
shot and a side of club soda yeah or we
would call in Chicago it would be a
cback or like a yeah the pickle back
yeah I get that that's the same thing as
a mixed drink no it's not in
there I yeah I've never theoretically be
I've never I've never seen or never even
had one offered or say do you want a
chaser to that at a bar they won't offer
no no no you'll ask yes yeah I've never
seen anyone ask I'm I'm not saying
you're wrong we would say so to back let
me let me get a shot shot of Jameson
soda back yeah I understand that's a I
don't know I don't think anybody's doing
that you're doing that at your house
that's even weirder than ordering milk
in public why sh as a grownup you not to
do shots at the house what do you mean
we're hanging out the [__] you mean
shots at the house the parents are gone
oh what a high school no I'm kid that
you have so you have some gird or
something like that some some gastro
issues what if you're asking for a
milk uh wow you got ulcers but can't let
go uh wow yeah no in my head this was at
your house I don't think you would ever
do that I pictured it was at a bar I
then raise the thing I've never asked
for a I've never seen anybody
saying the people that I see get like
I'll do a whiskey and a club soda that's
what they're drinking they're doing the
club as like this is what I'm drinking
and then I do a whack of whiskey to keep
me [__] 10 and two sure that's not a
shot glass though that's usually in a
rocks class or something you get it neat
mhm but yeah I don't think I've ever
which I've thought about switching over
to something like that yeah yeah they
just [__] me up sure I just drink them
like their beers dude that's my problem
I've tried this every like two years ago
why don't you go switch to Whiskey it's
a you know about two three drinks is a
whiskey soda thing next thing you know
I'm fighting my reflection wh soda yeah
they're not good in in one of my darker
moments of my life I was uh the only
booze we had in the house was a bottle
of Bitters and I that's not alcohol it
has alcohol in it yeah yeah but not like
that 35% really yeah yeah Jesus I and
it's got that like it's got that like
hot sauce top to make it drip yeah pop
that right off I thought you were just
going to sit there for an hour and a
half and make it drink poured it into
this big ass cup and then I don't know
what I was just hammered and I I mixed
it with almond milk and I get that in my
head though down it maybe see that that
doesn't that's what I would mix it with
you almost made amoretto yeah that's
what I like a Bailey type
Vibe no it didn't taste like that I'm
feeling kala D I'm feeling gut rot
dude I ate a bar
rag
crazy uh amaretta doesn't get a lot of
love it's older like it's got to me like
position in my head it's like a you know
it's like what your your great a had
always like am bottle of Amoro we always
had a we always had that for Angelica we
always haded that [__] at the house oh
yeah well you make a Dr Pepper with uh
Amoro and something else can't remember
what it was called we would always we
had it for Nutty Irishman okay um but it
had I don't know what the flavoring it's
like Cherry kind of bitters no amoretto
no bitters is that's wood all right
that's what
you
wood they give that to people who
swallow too many pills yeah uh you know
what's not you know what's not bad is
Jameson with a grand marer float o okay
not too
chabadel one you know what I always
hated it's apricot amoretta is it really
apricot kernels bitter almonds and Peach
Stones almond that's what it is almond
has an almond it has a sweet like almond
cookie flavor yeah underrated am moreto
on the Rocks not too shab with a cherry
in it you got to whack somebody after
that
though
somebody's draining upstairs in the tub
don't take the edge off before I get
back to work um you order that with a
shaking bloody hand you know what I
hated I don't know I I'm sure it hit
different people at different times but
like those trick shots that were like
not the the one I remember was a cement
mixer and you would send it to somebody
oh I was thinking like frisbee into a
basketball
H all right off the
roof Watch Me Drive My Car through the
shed hitting a baseball with a golf club
um it's going to ruin your
[__] uh no it was like cement mixers
where like you mix them and then by the
time you Ser like oh send my friend two
cement mixers over there and then they
like they stiffen up on you and you
can't drink them or they like they
almost killed a buddy of mine they like
it's like eating a spoon full of
cinnamon you know what I mean they Cur
it curdles you you take uh dude I
remember my Budd wanted they kill me I
didn't know you take like Bailey's like
an Irish Cream liquor and you put lime
juice in it is that what it is what the
[__] yeah sorry about that we get a shot
of cottage
cheese that's crazy this was at one of
the bar's huge trash suburb thing that
I'm sure a lot of people that you know
lot of booze talk here spend time in the
suburbs but this is more of a do you
remember the I don't know if we ever
talked the pizza place that would be in
a strip mall would get a little bit of
cash or like the sons would take it over
open a bar and open a bar next door it
was like connected yes and those bars
like seven of those popped up in like
the surrounding 20 minutes of us we had
one and they were like night not
nightclubs but they were like cooler we
have one in our hometown that uh
recently just sold off their liquor
license for a chunk of change but it was
a nice bar when you went in there for a
while a couple of regulars yeah yeah no
but these were like they would tried to
make them too cool or like the kids were
like this going to be like a claw and it
wasn't just like if they just made it
like a ball it'd be cool but it was like
Friday you would like go there on a
Friday night and it'd be like packed and
you're like what are we doing I'm like
that guy's [__] making mozzarella
sticks that right there rather be over
there with him yeah EA garlic knuts in a
hookah
lounge yeah we had like yeah smelling
Pizza though Jam you jam up the works a
little bit and we would go for [__]
uh
quizo huh on like Tuesday nights look at
you the Summers when you're in college
real Hellraiser I it was like a 200 you
want a $250 bar bill or something we
were after that we kids were looking had
the sights on trying to win that thing
he had two guys in a van with ear
pieces the 13th president was who like
an old school uhhuh uh all right let's
see here um this is from Dan Neil $10
shareholder so you can continue to blow
all your money and keep us entertained
thanks buddy buddy you got my oath
um uh all right this one's from toies
unpaid contractor long time uh listener
since sporting events are cashless now
is it garbage to offer cash straight to
the Beer vendors for a lesser price $11
beer for $7 cash I have a high success
rate of this by the way I think you get
a lot of lot of biters on that and then
what they just pocket the cash that's
not bad they I I worked at the US Open
one
year all the way up at the top in a
concession I was told that I was going
to be bartending like
dude he do you be cocktail bunch of hot
I got rope adoped into this [__]
nightmare situation I thought I was
going to be down on the floor at like
the Heineken Bar [__] living life
Andre Agy there popping beers for
[__] John Mack Andro and I was up at
the tippy top of [__] Arthur rash
stadium with [__] degenerates [__]
working like proper concessions MH and
I'll tell you this man they procedures
and this was 20 years ago it's like
super max the cameras are on you only
this one has access a key to the
register dropboxes coming by every 10
minutes pulling the money checking it
checking inventory it's real tight no
I'm sure if you can get away with that
I'm all about it oh yeah hey again
that's you know you're taking out the
big man you're you're you're waiting
your's 20 give me two I get that I'm big
fan of that
but I guess it would have to be drafts
but a lot of places do do like stadiums
do drafts I don't think it would have to
be drafts almost exclusively no no it's
all about can it's all about the
aluminum can bottles and stuff yeah I've
been out the game about five
years milk backs over
here take it easy cement mixer uh yeah
it's all cans now Berry bitters over
there you know that they have that [__]
locked down because there's some guy who
goes I used to work the concessions at
the bleachers down there wrigly field
made two G's every sure they used to
100% M basically in business for
yourself yeah one for you two for me
type thing I remember there's got to be
cuz I remember I was trying to buy an
iced coffee that's what they sell on the
beach now down the shore like there's
like ice coffee vendors like the fudgy
WGY man I Know It uh and my wife wanted
uh like I maybe I got an ice coffee and
she just wanted like a cup of ice cuz
she had like a water or something and
she's like oh can I have a cup of ice
he's like no my boss counts cups so if
the ice coffee guy has the teen the high
teenager on lock I got to I would assume
sure the [__] stadiums guy they make
their money hey I respect the move buddy
shave the points when you can sure uh
nothing wrong with a cash price big cash
price nothing wrong with it I'm talking
to a contractor now talking cash pricing
they're all about that yeah cash is King
they're all about that what if I pay
cash off 10% really of the total price
he he
left he did not play 25,000 I'll give
you 1,500 now what would it be you what
you got to figure cuz you really just
not that I would ever do this but you're
really just cutting the tax out yeah so
like a 10% discount yeah 10
15% you take 10 10 15% off I'll do cash
but they're probably all right but I got
to do it on the weekend
that's side work nobody looking over
your shoulder where the [__] were you
all
day yeah I do it on the weekend um and I
think the time it's going to take to do
the job is going to be a little bit
longer we got to stretch that
out yeah I don't know I I gotta I gotta
I got to talk to him about it little bit
of wiggle room you know what I mean is
it would a check count as cash yeah that
would not really so you got to get you
got to go get that what you got to get
that yeah wow I think right a check cuz
he's got to deposit a check then there's
the the whole idea is so the money
doesn't go into the banking
system not that I would ever do that I'm
just saying in general that's how these
Scoundrels Opera speaking in hyperbole
here uhhuh it's a comedy program yeah so
topographically
cograph uh yeah so I think he would then
you keep the cash yeah I got to tell you
how to work World works you just as if a
check you just as if a check works you
just ask if a check was Cash yeah I mean
your your mom did dress you last week so
made to
cash make it out to cash yeah but they
that's still you got to take it to the
bank you don't want the bank involved
uhuh when you have a check rent out to
cash I'm not sure just cash it right do
you have to do that you can't write a
check to cash and give to someone
else no yes you can just make it out to
cash and then pay to the order of I
don't know if they do this anymore but
you be able you would be able to go to
their that bank I mean I'm sure that's
how [__] Banks got ripped off no so
that it can be cash or deposited by
anyone so instead of I'm giving we would
write like I'm giving this to you know
Kevin Ryan whatever only he can deposit
it but if it's made out the cash that's
anybody that can't fly anymore there's
no [__] way that seems like the wild
west that's a what so everybody's just
on the honor System that doesn't nobody
who would do that
only a pharaoh table would take that a
what in Tombstone it's an old car game
um saw Tombstone the other day just
start watching look over get a [__]
hat on um that doesn't nobody can be
doing that
anymore I would imagine yeah but who
would risk that then what if the check
gets lost uh so uh right am I nuts yeah
this is this is saying you can do it as
a way to withdraw money if you forgot
your bank card your team card yes that
that makes sense here's a check from
Henry Foley I'm Henry Foley here's my
license I'm making it out the cash give
me a grand or that was before yeah
before ATF or if you don't know the
person's name why you giving a guy cash
if you don't know his you guy giving a
check you don't know his name some guy's
working on your house you're going
You're not asking his name it's for
hookers what are you talking about maybe
you forgot you everyone has been in a
situation where they where you're around
someone for too long to ask their name
again so you're just going to risk a
check no you couldn't write him a check
what Toby why you don't know his can you
spell his last
name you mean the guy who I booked 500
plane tickets for oh [__] that's right
and got him um hotel rooms you don't
know his middle name I send him money
every week you know his middle name uh
exactly yeah make it at the cage I do
and also it doesn't go to his middle who
who the [__] writes your middle name on
a check I like to be
formal it out the game that's nuts to me
make it out the G I've been writing a
lot of checks recently have you feel
pretty good about it you breaking any
necks tough guy cashing checks and
breaking necks like a basketball team
over things are bouncing all over the
place oh man [__] Frank abig nail Jun
over here dude Chang the routing number
the the routing number fear the fear in
me of writing a check you're nut I've
only successfully personally out of my
bank account have probably
successfully
written you got to keep $9 million in
there just to make sure you can sleep at
night I've probably successfully written
six checks in my whole life and I
probably attempted to WR written wrote
like 12 I bounced probably six checks
yeah I haven't read in a long time I
haven't done I bounced a couple in North
Carolina at the grocery store oh oh was
bad
shape I make this out the cage
financially and personally emotionally
sure that's a receipt imagine bouncing a
check for Uncrustables yeah uh it was
were you at least going for a big load
like a big payday no just get a Snickers
bar
I like the leowski do you take personal
checks here uh it was I was living on
um bagged lettuce that had like cabbage
and carrots in it you know what I'm
talking about that wait say that again
bagged lettuce shred pre-made salad Sal
Mi man they were big are they still big
uh they look a little dingy when I see
them now they do lot of moisture in them
bag they used to be popping yeah
remember dude my mom but this wasn't the
one with the dressing and [__] in it it
was just bag salad and I would do that
with uh balsamic like Italian vinegret
in the in the Shaker and I would crumble
up uh Saltines in there pretty good if
you were starving it was all right this
North Carolina it's like depression
croutons dude sure sure I remember
remember when I lost my job uh on drugs
what you put your eyes back in your head
[__] everything tastes good on bur
said yeah that was high [__] up it's a
bad spot dude I turn that to be a movie
star and I was [__] planting palm
trees in the
sand sounds like a bad country
song palm trees in the sand
they got to go you know I mean we've
talked about it but that power move of
to be an actor you moov to North
kakalaka I
mean um I remember uh I stopped working
for my family no money I think I had
like 80 bucks right and I went to the
grocery store Acme shout out to the aamy
down here on passun was it on passun
Avenue I think it was in South philadel
what oh right around the corner from the
Street this I was living at Titan Street
oh you hadn't moved in yet no but I know
that soon yeah it was like right around
the corner
yeah and man they had like hot dogs 10
for 10 remember Acme used to do the 10
for 10 you like 10 packages for they
were a dollar a piece dude I spent I I
bought like 42 packages of hot dogs CU I
was like this is my I got to hunker down
I don't know when my next check's coming
in I got to really get some food for the
next couple of weeks and God sent you me
I remember you lent me 20 bucks mean I
really [__]
and you didn't have it dude
um I remember one of the best deals of
the grocery store ever which I don't
know if you guys are yogurt people but
when they would do the yogurts for a
dollar I hate dude I used to work at
acne and you [__] dirt bags would
come through and buy them by the cart
buying 78 is there a limit on the 10 for
10 yogurts hey TS it ain't working
you're 400 lb
Patty man Patty Foley thought she hit
the Fountain of Youth with those puppies
man we used to go with man there was
something about a middle-aged woman who
drank the Kool-Aid on what a yogurt
could do for you they were the they were
the first real like man this product's
really going to CH it's good it's probio
they were the first one pushing
probiotics Activa Jamie Jam Lee Curtis
that lion hey hold your thongue sure I
love her but I'm just saying she had
everybody brainwashed this is I'm
talking Dan and fruit on the bottom
[__] eat that shitty yogurt just to
get to the [__] blueberries on the
bottom dude and [__] Cash Out Hard
Candy cherries at the bottom was like
jelly you ever you ever get jammed up no
milk for cereal and go yogurt and cereal
it's great it's all right not bad but I
don't like yogurt what you're supposed
to do as a gentleman is put the yogurt
on the bottom in the cereal on top
you're not slapping it on like it's sour
cream no like like you're spackling
throwing
mud oh God uh all right let's see here
let's do one or two more um H this one's
from Jack is it garbage if more than one
person in your family still drives a
Saturn yes yes it is more than one's
tough one I'll give you because
depending on there's always somebody in
a flex period That's not doing the best
and not to say they're not going to rise
out of that but they're in a US car it's
the Saturn it's the whatever some of
them have lasted for sure I'm not saying
it's a bad car maybe it's a 16-year-old
driving it maybe it's a 72y old maybe
it's a guy and Uncle down on his luck
whatever I get that but multiple people
in your family still driving Saturns
that's [__] nuts I wonder what it
would have
took for one of my parents to buy a
Saturn we were all always 100% American
cars we
weren't that's nuts Nissan baby yeah
never turn quick was Saturn one of the
they had the like like automatic seat
belt yes oh my friend Liam had that
thing like a
[__] no like Joe peshy sitting in the
back seat [__] taking you [__]
wrap you up I was always a fat kid too I
was afraid he was going to [__] there
wasn't a other belt either no it was
just the one it was just the shoulder
[__] crack your spine in half dud
you'd slip out of that thing like a
nighty and nine times out of 10 it would
never retract so it was just wild loose
mhm oh I hate it it made no sense to me
yeah dude they sucked they dude those
cars would have a power seat belt with
roll down Windows get your [__] head
out of your ass we need the [__] when
was the last car you had that had rolled
down Windows like the the manual johnes
crankers couple of crankers
uh a Honda Accord hatchback what year
were you whipping that around this is 96
97 wow yeah I didn't have a car from
99 I didn't have a car I mean it told
like hold on I didn't have a car in for
damn near 20 years from
until
2019 I didn't have a
car and that car was my was my parents I
would argue till the new Jeep is your
car I paid for the old Jeep But the
lease was under my mother's name so it's
whose car what do you mean what that was
your mother's car I paid for it though
okay but I paid for it okay but her yeah
it was in her name it was her car sure
okay that's all I would if you're 17 and
you're making the payments in your mom's
name then that could be like yeah that's
your car at 45 if it's in your mom's
name that's her car all right do you see
what I'm saying she paid for the
insurance and the easy best oh yeah and
half the guest she she borrowed it also
made her do oil change every other time
that's funny man I she also wanted at a
mall by not taking her hand
off goddamn trooper that lady have Patty
Foley you anything for her kids I'll
tell you that as long as I can smok in
here you're all
screwed just a pile of heaters next to
her I'll smoke you out like like Denzel
in Training Day when they were digging
that kitchen
up a man I
stink oh God that's [__]
awesome use are in for a long
weekend blowing smoke right in their
face dude cart of smokes in a neck
pillow his broad's in it to win it oh
does my smoke bother
you
oh Jesus
Christ I
drove my the I drove a car up until
10 nine or 10 that had rolled that had
rolled down Windows I sorry [__]
sounded like old time radio I was trying
to I was trying to hor us my my windows
really my boys in the front lines
fighting the rolling the windows yeah
Remember by
American I was in college 2009 eight or
nine 10 still had to roll down Windows I
don't mind them if they came back for
whatever reason yeah but now would be a
choice it's a tough look at that time
sure I don't think I had a real rough CD
player in there and let me tell you
something sometimes that knob came off
oh yeah the passenger one was off and
you were working with that little metal
little metal piece and that that hurt
your fingers in a winter yeah also it
was tough to roll up the ones in the
back you had to
[__] work the traps baby reaching
back there I would have to do it dude so
start raiding on you on the DT bike [__]
dude you're all over the road at that
point H all right we got to wrap it up
gang gang I'm going to tell you this all
the time mhm speak for all three of us
here on the program sure we love you to
death yep and we're going to see you
next week peace peace